[Musik]
unsere rufe sind in den letzten jahren
lauter geworden die rufe von uns frauen
nach rechten chancen und respekt
bewegungen wie nie tun haben millionen
von uns auf die straße gebracht und
aufgezeigt dass männer und frauen immer
noch ungleich behandelt werden was die
welt braucht ihr sind sichtbare frauen
frauen wie die ehemalige politikerin
yolanda spiels hegglin die sich alleine
gegen den sexismus der schweizer
medienbranche stellt und gewinnt frauen
wie die schwedin erika lasst die eine
der letzten wirklichen männerdomänen
aufmischt pornografie und frauen wie die
deutsche verteidigungsministerin
annegret kramp karrenbauer die eine
armee von 200.000 befehligt
diese frauen spielen die hauptrolle in
dieser serie
weil sie aktiv dazu beitragen dass die
welt so an gerechten ort wird sowie dass
viele von uns versuchen auch ich
[Musik]
ich heiße patrizia laeri als
wirtschaftsjournalistin beschäftige ich
mich oft mit der gläsernen decke und
fehlenden frauen in führungspositionen
wir frauen haben ein geldproblem wir
verdienen weniger als männer auf
gleichen positionen als mutter kenne ich
die belastung die berufstätige frauen
mit kindern aushalten müssen und als
feministin ärgert es mich dass uns meist
nur männer die welt erklären das will
ich mit meiner eigenen
wirtschaftssendung ändern rosa hütte die
autorin dieses films und ich wollen in
dieser ersten folge der serie wissen was
können wir tun um macht weiblicher zu
machen
antworten geben frauen die es selber wie
es ganz nach oben geschafft haben sowie
die deutsche verteidigungsministerin
annegret kramp karrenbauer eine
frauenquote zwingt dazu dass man sich
nach frauen umschaut und dass man ihnen
die chance gibt sondern auf einmal
feststeht ob da gibts doch frauen wir
haben da jemand der die position
besetzen kann
die vize präsidentin des
österreichischen wirtschaftsverbandes
martha schultz wenn wir mütter werden
dann wird erwartet dass wir wieder hier
zu hause das kind betreuen vielleicht
aber teilzeit arbeiten gehen und damit
veränderungen brauchen und für mich eine
der veränderung wird es immer wieder bei
dem thema die kinderbetreuung oder die
schweizer bundesrätin simonetta
sommaruga
ja ich habe eigentlich den eindruck die
macht der männer ist frauen zu spalten
und das muss man als frau durchschauen
[Musik]
die welt verändert sich für uns frauen
wir sind so mächtig wie noch nie und
fliegen so hoch hinaus wie wir wollen
wir sind uns sicher das ist gut für die
welt studien belegen dass staatschef
innen die korona krise besser bewältigen
und das unternehmen mit vielen frauen an
der spitze
langfristig erfolgreicher und
nachhaltiger wirtschaften
trotzdem sind mächtige frauen immer noch
selten zb liegt der frauenanteil in der
geschäftsleitung der 200 größten
unternehmen in österreich bei nur 8,4
prozent in der schweiz bei 8,8 prozent
und in deutschland bei 9 prozent
von 193 staaten der vereinten nationen
regieren frauen nur 19
[Musik]
und nur ein drittel der abgeordneten im
deutschen bundestag ist weiblich als
größter stolperstein auf dem weg nach
oben wir uns frauen gehen nach wie vor
die familiengründung
aber stimmt das wirklich
was hatten meine kinder auf deine
karriere für einen einfluss hatten sie
überhaupt ein
also wenn ich mir die studien anschaue
dann hätte ich ja innerhalb von wenigen
monaten 70 an einkommen eingebüßt hatte
dass in zehn jahren nicht mehr aufgeholt
weil er in teilzeit jobs und weniger
interessanten tätigkeiten auf das aber
nicht passiert das kann ja gar nicht
sein
total spannenden beruf absolut und das
war auch nur möglich also meine karriere
weiter voranzutreiben
auch für meinen mann der seine karriere
auch volker beide haben das gemacht weil
meine mutter zu hause bei uns gelebt hat
und dieses privileg gehabt natürlich
fast immer und das aber trotzdem ein
paar mal erzählen rahmen dieses projekt
gesagt habe jetzt bin ich schon wieder
nicht so als würde ich schon wieder
immer am pre nicht mit einer rabenmutter
aber hast du wirklich ein schlechtes
gewissen oder sind das leere sprüche bei
mir vielleicht eher sprüche ich sehr
aber wirklich wie meine freundinnen mann
im feld frauen sich wirklich damit
quälen mit diesen schlechten gewissen
permanent ich persönlich sage dann immer
glückliche mutter glückliche kinder der
anteil frauen in der deutschen regierung
ist in den letzten jahren gestiegen
eine von ihnen treffe ich im cdu
hauptquartier in berlin
annegret kramp karrenbauer ist deutscher
verteidigungsministerin und warfen 2018
bis anfang 2000 21 parteivorsitzende der
cdu hat angela merkel in dieser position
abgelöst
und sie ist mutter von drei kindern
hier stelle ich darum eine frage kann
man einem mann so nie stellen würde wie
vereinbart man dann als
spitzenpolitikerin das familienleben mit
drei kindern
ja ich bin ja so langsam da
reingewachsen weil ich meine kinder eben
auch zu meinem politischen engagement
sozusagen in die zeit hinein geboren
wurden
und gerade in der zeit in der ich die
karriere schritte gemacht habe mein mann
eben sich stärker in der familie
engagiert hat aber wie jede berufstätige
mutter egal in welchem bereich sie
berufstätig ist sie gehen diesen weg und
werden immer begleitet vom schlechten
gewissen weil sie sich immer fragen habe
ich jetzt genug zeit investiert leide
das kind darunter sie sich immer fragen
bei jeder schlechten noten in der schule
liegt das jetzt daran dass ich nicht zu
hause war und das ist manchmal wirklich
das dilemma in dem mann steckt wenn man
nicht die zeit für zu hause an einsetzen
kann wie man sich eigentlich wünscht
haben die beispiele wenn sie
zurückblicken die wehgetan haben also
was was mich wirklich mal sehr getroffen
hat war das eine meiner söhne gesagt hat
weißt du bist schon bei vielen
sportveranstaltungen nur wenn ich
fußball spiele
dann bist du nie dabei dass das sind
punkte die die einen dann wirklich
nachdenklich machen noch wirklich
schmerzen
das war auch als sich sportministerin
war und auch daneben her wie sich das
gehört sehr engagiert im
schulförderverein und damit man
sozusagen mir nicht nachsagen kann ich
würde mich nicht für meine kinder
einsetzen interessieren wann haben sie
dann gemerkt dass sie als frau eben
nicht die gleichen chancen haben wie
ihre männlichen fans also war das
wirklich als die mutter wurden
interessanterweise schon ein bisschen
früher also als ich angefangen habe zu
studieren wer gab es einen professor
kurz am ende seiner akademischen
karriere
und der hat bei einer vorlesung eine
kommilitonin gefragt haben sie
eigentlich einen freund den verlobten
und hat gesagt ja und dann hat jetzt ihr
gesagt und warum sitzen sie denn hier im
hörsaal
also das war wirklich ewig gestrig das
war zum beispiel so ein punkt der mich
da empört hat und dann anfang der 80er
war dieses dieses thema natürlich habe
ich kinder und bin voll berufstätig noch
nicht so selbstverständlich sondern zwar
sehr viel mehr die debatte wie wähle ich
mein leben planen will ich kinder wenn
ja steige ich dann aus dem beruf aus und
ich habe keinen mann zum damaligen
zeitpunkt gekannt der sich ernsthaft
darüber gedanken macht er sondern alle
gesagt klar will karriere machen und
irgendwann werde ich auch eine frau und
kinder haben punkt
in wien besuche ich eine weitere frau
die es als mutter in eine machtposition
geschafft hat sie heißt martha schultz
und leitet zusammen mit ihrem bruder
eines der größten tourismusunternehmens
österreichs die schultz gruppe ihnen
gehören diese anbahnen ski lief der
hotels und einiges mehr
außerdem ist die vize-präsidentin des
mächtigsten wirtschaftsverbandes
österreichs des bka über den dächern von
wien erzählt sie mir wie sie es
geschafft hat als alleinerziehende
mutter diese karriere hinzulegen
ich wüsste nicht wie ich das als
alleinerziehende alles geschafft hätte
jetzt meine persönlichen weg meine
karriere
also ich habe ein sehr gutes
familiennetzwerk aber es war natürlich
schon sehr schwierig und meinte dass er
sagen mein tagesablauf ich sehr
diszipliniert und ich möchte gerne dass
die frauen die generationen noch mal
dass dies einfach besser haben und ich
sehe es auch auf meine aufgabe ich weiß
was es heißt als alleinerzieherin mit
kindern mit allen möglichkeiten oder
nicht möglichkeiten dem mann hat an
karriereweg zu gehen ich selbst im
unternehmen versuche das auch allen
meinen mitarbeiterinnen mit zu geben
aber ich sage mal familie ist ja nicht
nur weiblich sondern familienarbeit ist
auch männlich versuche auch das den
herrn mit zu geben wenn wir mütter
werden dann wird erwartet dass wir
wieder hier zu hause das kind betreuen
vielleicht der beetle teilzeit arbeiten
gehen und sehr viele frauen die das
kriegen die betreuung nach einem jahr
dann hast du mir klingt schon in die
kinderbetreuung wie man es gibt länder
wo es überhaupt kein problem ich muss
die baby crash gibt und die
kinderbetreuung schon mit drei monaten
dass ich völlig selbstverständlich und
darum gehen wir jetzt eine studie in
auftrag um diese rollenbilder zu
hinterfragen und wie man das ändern kann
wie schaffen wir das in österreich um
wich der verglasung im frankophilen raum
und dem skandinavischen raum beim
österreichischen wirtschaftsverband geht
martha schultz mit gutem beispiel voran
vor zwei jahren hat sie als
vize-präsidentin durchgesetzt dass die
wk einen eigenen betriebskindergarten
eröffnet
solche sind immer noch sehr selten in
deutschland in der schweiz und auch in
österreich
wir sind ganztägig ganzjährig geöffnet
wir sind bilingual und wir sind jetzt
hier in der spürnasen ecke damit man sie
auch a bisserl in dem bereich technik
begeistern können wir machen garten wo
die kinder irgendwann grünes blatt und
das mikroskop wo sie aufschauen können
also einfach die kinder aufs leben
vorzubereiten
wie entscheidend ist nun so eine
betreuungsinfrastruktur wie sich sehen
und auch betriebskindergärten für mich
hat das thema das sich zeigen möchte wie
es möglich dass unternehmen die
wirtschaftskammer ist ja auch einen ein
unternehmen ein großes dass man sein
kann wie immer betriebskindergarten
finanziert und initiiert
frauen gehören ins haus ihre natürliche
bestimmung ist es mutter zu sein
mit diesem argument hat man uns
jahrtausende lang aus der öffentlichkeit
und von der macht ferngehalten
im neuen testament steht zum beispiel
geschrieben dass die frau dem mann
gehorchen muss und öffentlich nicht
sprechen darf bis 19 58 verwaltete der
vater oder ehemann das vermögen einer
deutschen und sie durfte ohne die
unterschrift eines landes kann bankkonto
eröffnen und männer verweigerten frauen
jahrhundertelang das politische
mitbestimmungsrecht suffragetten wurden
die us amerikanischen und britischen
frauenrechtlerinnen genannt die anfangs
des zwanzigsten jahrhunderts damit
begannen für das stimmrecht der frauen
zu kämpfen
die schweiz wiederum war bis 1971 keine
richtige demokratie das wort demokratie
heißt aber herrschaft des volkes und mir
scheint
die frauen auch zum volk gehört die frau
gehörten staus dieser mutter sein traum
ist es ist kein echtes drama steht ja
erst dann wurde nämlich das
frauenstimmrecht auf bundesebene
eingeführt
kaum vorstellbar aber meine mutter gab
auch nicht als mündige bürgerin als sie
volljährig wurde 20 21 jetzt sich die
einführung des frauenstimmrechts in der
schweiz zum fünfzigsten mal und das wird
ordentlich gefeiert mit viel
medienberichterstattung und mit diversen
ausstellungen zum thema einer davon
heißt thomas 20 21 es ist eine freilicht
ausstellung in der altstadt von bern der
schweizer hauptstadt
gewürdigt werden frauen die für die
schweiz und die gleichberechtigung
großes geleistet haben
nicht darunter ist simonetta sommaruga
obwohl auch sie zu diesen frauen gehört
sie ist teile siebenköpfigen
landesregierung der schweiz dem
bundesrat 2020 landete sie im ranking
des us amerikanischen
wirtschaftsmagazins forbes auf platz 56
der 100 mächtigsten frauen der welt als
ich in den bundesrat gewählt wurde waren
wir vier frauen eine frauenmehrheit
diese für schweizer verhältnisse
verrückte zeit dauerte 14 monaten
dann war es vorbei heute sind wir zwei
und viele finden zwei doch eigentlich
genug
[Musik]
seit über zehn jahren kämpft sie als
spitzenpolitikerin für chancengleichheit
zum beispiel für elternzeit oder faire
löhne
sie hat vorgeschlagen dass wir die
ausstellung hommage 20 21 für diesen
film zusammen besuchen
warum sind wir dann so ein sonderfall in
der schweiz als gleichstellung anbelangt
ja die schweiz hat tatsächlich also sehr
später ich die eigentlich eine richtige
demokratie geworden erst 1971 wurden die
frauen vollständige mündige bürgerinnen
dieses landes diese frauen zeichnet aus
die waren auf ihre art immer mutig die
haben sich exponiert sie wurden aber
auch ausgegrenzt also die mussten das
ertragen dass sie dann etwas besonderes
sagen dass man sich vielleicht auch
schräg angeschaut hat und ich denke
gerade eine chance
die dann wirklich hin gestanden ist die
mutige dinge gesagt hat zwar eine
bürgerliche politikerin also keine linke
politikerin und musste dann sicher auch
von ihrem politischen umfeld sich eben
auch immer wieder emanzipieren
sie war bei der einführung des
frauenstimmrechts eine der ersten in den
nationalrat gewählt worden sind sie hat
jus studiert sie hat mich immer
beeindruckt und sie hat den satz geprägt
aber jetzt verstehe ich warum man sagt
die frauen gehören ins haus nämlich ins
rathaus ins bundeshaus und sie hat
dieses diesem begriff haus sowie sich
neu interpretiert sie hatte immer sehr
viel humor
ich staune wie freue ich mich mit einer
bundesrätin hier in der berner altstadt
bewegen kann und auch darüber wie frei
simonetta sommaruga mit mir spricht
unterwegs erzählt sie mir wie wichtig
sie es findet dass frauen sichtbarer
werden zum beispiel mit ausstellungen
wie diese ich glaube das ist wirklich
ein thema dass frauen eigentlich im
öffentlichen raum nicht stattfinden und
nicht sichtbar sind und dass sie deshalb
auch nicht gibt und ich glaube es geht
ja immer wieder auch darum dass man raum
einnimmt das
dass es auch einen platz gibt und da
denke ich sind diese fotos jetzt hier
und diese geschichten
das ist auch ein stück präsenz der
frauen im öffentlichen raum das ist iris
von roten sagt er dann ein buch
geschrieben trauen im laufgitter sie hat
die wirtschaftliche abhängigkeiten
frauen thematisiert und ich denke da hat
sie einen ganz wunden punkt getroffen
und sehr sehr viel gegenwind bekommen
nicht nur von männern sondern eben auch
von frauen
das hat sich stark belastet diese
wirtschaftliche abhängigkeit der frauen
ist ein thema das auch martha schultz
beschäftigt zurück in wien erzählt sie
mir davon wie es war mit frauen
aufzuwachsen die ganz selbstverständlich
unternehmen gegründet und geleitet haben
dass unternehmerinnen gegend ist man
schon ein bisschen in die wiege gelegt
worden weil er natürlich einen
unternehmen hinein geboren wurde und
auch groß geworden wurde also beim
mittagstisch gab es natürlich bei uns
das thema von wie geht es im unternehmen
auch wenn es probleme gab und
aufgewachsen bin ich ja sehr viel bei
meiner urgroßmutter die das unternehmen
gegründet hat und die hat man natürlich
auch viele geschichten erzählt zum
unternehmertum und auch welche
verantwortung dass man hat ja und von
musik sorgen also würde ich sagen ist
mir in die wiege gelegt worden
was ist ihnen da in erinnerung geblieben
dann was fürsprecherin gesichter
das ist ein ganz besonderer spruch dazu
immer gesagt du musst immer selbst so
viel geld haben dass du dir eine
strumpfhose kaufen kann schon mal zu
damaliger zeit waren strumpfhosen ganz
exklusive artikel und sie wollte mir
einfach mit geben die unabhängigkeit ja
dass man immer so viel geld haben soll
dass man unabhängig als frau sein kann
und dass denke sehr oft das ist mir sehr
wichtig
frauen soll es in zukunft genauso leicht
fallen wie ihr die gläserne decke zu
durchbrechen oder eine firma zu gründen
dafür setzt sich martha schultz ein sie
veranstaltet darum alljährlich einen
unternehmerinnen kongress in österreich
und das ist längst nicht alles
wir haben wir auch das zukunft frauen
programm
das heißt dass wir frauen in den
verschiedensten bereichen fortbilden
aber auch selbstbewusstsein austausch
netzwerken bis ich ein programm dass das
wirtschaftsministerium die
wirtschaftskammer und auch die industrie
gemeinsam unterstützen mittlerweile
haben wir ja fast 300 abgängerinnen und
wir haben auch eine datei mit schon vor
knapp 800 frauen in allen berufszweigen
ich sage auch jeden aber wenn man sagt
er sucht eine frau in 24 stunden nämlich
hin fünf qualifizierte frauen aber für
gehobenes management auf mit einer
chefin die martha schultz fällt es
frauen leichter karriere zu machen
schade nur gibt es zu wenige davon ab ob
man eine chefin
ich hatte noch nie eine spricht die
wände weiß was ich auch extrem
interessiert würde in bezug auf dieses
thema
stellen wir uns mal vor so die letzten
10.000 jahre hätten frauen regiert am
start männer wie wird die welt dann aus
was für ein spannendes
gedankenexperiment mir ist es vor allem
wichtig dass mal die diskussion in gang
gekommen ist ist macht eigentlich
richtig definiert warum kommentiert man
sie nicht mit rücksichtsnahme
einfühlsamkeit freundlichkeit
und was wenn klassische männerbastionen
wie zum beispiel das militär seit jeher
zur hälfte aus frauen bestehen würden
auch das ist allerdings nur ein
gedankenexperiment erst seit 20 jahren
sind frauen zum beispiel in der
bundeswehr überhaupt überall zugelassen
wenn sie ihre truppen besucht ist
annegret kramp karrenbauer also meistens
nur von männern umgeben
vielen dank freue mich auf den besuch
hier in idar oberstein im deutschen
bundesland rheinland pfalz ist ein teil
der deutschen artillerie- stationiert
ihr fällt rosalie erst so richtig auf
wie wenig kontakt zu frauen annegret
kramp karrenbauer in ihrem alltag wohl
hat und wie durchsetzungsfähig sie sein
muss um erfolgreich tausende von männern
zu führen
sie sind zu einer 1000 mitarbeiter innen
wie würden sie das ist natürlich ein
riesenunternehmen wenn sie so wollen hat
so ein bisschen was von konzernen an
sich aber das ist auch meine erfahrung
der letzten monate und jahre
es gibt unglaublich viele wirklich tolle
menschen in der bundeswehr selbst die
diesen auftrag mit hartmut betreiben und
das macht mir die aufgabe auch leichter
haben sie
für spuren hinterlassen das wäre auch in
punkto frauen
es ist insgesamt gelungen die bundeswehr
wieder sichtbarer zu machen in der
gesellschaft auch akzeptiert da sich das
bahnfahren den uniformen
wir sind mittlerweile bei den als
arbeitgeber auf platz zwei wir steigern
den frauenanteil und zwar in allen
truppenteilen aber das ist ein hartes
brett aufzubohren aber wir legen eben
auch um besonderen fokus darauf bei der
rekrutierung von frauen aber auch bei
dem umgang das klar ist bundeswehr
bietet platz für jeden für jedes
geschlecht für jede orientierung und das
muss die bundeswehr auch ausstrahlen und
auch das ist eine gemeinsame aufgabe die
wir uns vorgenommen haben
der anteil soldaten in der bundeswehr
steigt zwar aber nur langsam
2003 lagen um 3 prozent heute sind es
noch 13
die meisten üben auch innerhalb der
bundeswehr typische frauen tätigkeiten
aus bei der sanität sind zum beispiel
fast die hälfte aller soldaten
soldatinnen ganz anders hier die acht
ziele ri ist eine truppengattung in der
es nur sehr wenige frauen liebt
letztendlich dafür verantwortlich alles
überprüfen was die beiden machen und die
rakete auch das nämlich ihr ziel
warum das so ist erklärt mir
oberstleutnant michael schienen und es
wäre doch mittlerweile auch mehr fragen
warum sehen wir hier zu wenig brachte
insbesondere bei den schweren waffen
system one panzerhaubitzen erfordert das
natürlich eine gewisse körperliche
robustheit ein geschoss 155 millimeter
dick wiegt etwa 43 kilo 60 dieser
geschosse müssen oft munition die
handwerker noch blitze also dass das für
die eine oder andere frau doch auch eine
aber nicht heraus
für mich war das heute auch eine gute
gelegenheit mir etwas anzuschauen in der
bundeswehr artillerie was oft in der
öffentlichkeit gar nicht so bekannt ist
wenn man sich das bild eines soldaten
einer soldatin vorstellt viele können
sich etwas vorstellen unter der marine
und der luftwaffe unter fallschirmjägern
aber relativ wenig unter artillerie und
das ist ein ganz faszinierender bereich
und ich bin sehr dankbar dass ich mir
davon heute wirklich selbst auch einen
eindruck machen konnte die armee ist
tatsächlich immer noch ein männerverein
nicht nur in deutschland
überraschen ist trotzdem sind acht
europäische verteidigungsministerien in
frauenhand zum beispiel in deutschland
der schweiz oder in den niederlanden und
weile fels funken heißt die
niederländische kollegin von annegret
kramp karrenbauer
sie ist der meinung dass wir frauen uns
auf dem weg zur macht manchmal selber im
weg stehen
sie hatten auch mal gesagt frauen
müssten mehr wie geht die langstrumpf
sein wie haben sie das gemeint wir
frauen sagen zu viel dass wir das nicht
können und wie viel angst rumpf hat
gesagt ich habe das noch nie getan also
ich kann das ich schaffe das
und das soll wir machen wer sollen
richtig denken dass wir das können und
dann schaffen wir das auch schon
verstehe ich aber schon auch richtig sie
sagen sehr vieles liegt auch an den
frauen selber und wie viel liegt dann am
system das einen auch nicht sehr
familien und frauenfreundlich ist wir
haben schon viel gemacht um die das
system viel familienfreundlicher und
frauenfreundlicher zu machen
aber es liegt sagen jetzt auch noch viel
an den frau zum beispiel gibt es auch
noch immer zu wenig frauen die sich
bewerben und frauen denken auf mehr als
männer dass sie etwas nicht gut und die
männer machen dass wir machen das so und
das ist ja da so die frauen sich auch
ändern
die sollen dann auch mehr für sich
selbst und ihrer familie denke inwiefern
könnte dann auch die ganze gesellschaft
profitieren wenn mehr frauen in
spitzenpositionen sind ja ich denke dass
die gesellschaft besteht einfach aus
männer und frauen und ich glaube dass
beh haben unterschiedliche kompetenzen
und wenn man die zusammen nicht dann
werden die entschlüsse denke ich besser
dann gibt es eine bessere situation was
halten sie dann von frauenquoten
ich warne davor aber da haben sie eine
andere position als annegret kramp
karrenbauer berger 30 m vielleicht
endlich auch mal wenn ich noch mal mit
mir darüber reden aber ich fand die
aktion dass sie sich geändert habe wieso
verstehen sie es ja weil es wirklich war
ganz kleine schritte sind sie jetzt zu
nehmen
die cdu hat sich unter der führung von
annegret kramp karrenbauer dazu
entschieden eine frauenquote einzuführen
ab 2025 sollen vorstandsposten abgreifen
zur hälfte von männern und frauen
besetzt sein
eine kehrtwende denn sie war er gegen
eine quote ich weiß noch dass ich meine
erste politische debatte in der cdu auf
einem kreisparteitag hatte es war eine
strittige debatte ich habe sie geführt
mit der kreisvorsitzende der
frauen-union und wir haben uns
gestritten über die frauenquote die
kollegin war dafür und ich verstecke
dagegen getreu dem motto gute frauen
brauchen keine quote so und dann habe
ich selbst im laufe meines lebens
gemerkt es ist für frauen immer noch ein
unterschied karriere und beruf und
familie unter einen hut zu bringen und
ich selbst habe auch an einer stelle
meines beruflichen lebens von einer
quoten situation profitiert und das war
mein sprungbrett
ich bin eine quotenfrau
ich habe kein problem weil ein
entscheidender schritt in meiner
karriere
darauf beruht dass der platz auf der
liste einen quotenplatz ein frauen platz
war es gibt zwei sätze die mir meinem
politischen leben oft begegnet sind
der einsatz ist so einer für
neueinsteiger der heißt wir machen dass
er 30 jahren so das braucht man nicht zu
ändern und der zweite satz ist ja wir
hätten ja gerne eine frau genommen aber
wir haben leider keine gefunden und eine
frauenquote zwingt dazu dass man sich
nach frauen umschaut und dass man ihnen
die chance gibt und auf einmal feststeht
ob da gibts doch frauen
wir haben da jemand der die position
besetzen kann und eine volkspartei
funktioniert im grunde genommen nur nach
dem prinzip der quote weil sie schauen
immer bei einer liste welche kandidaten
haben sie sind die gut verteilt männer
frauen alle berufe
regional gut verteilt im grunde genommen
alles gewisse quoten und ich habe nie
einsehen können warum nur beim thema
frau damit etwas negatives verbunden
wird auf ich die immer wieder öffentlich
für die frauenquote ein
hier in einer diskussion mit dem
präsidenten des schweizerischen
arbeitgeberverbandes valentin vogt
erfolgt von der verhaltensökonomie eine
ist keine sich auf 30 bis 40 prozent
scheint ihre minderheiten bringen und
bis bewegen und ich weiß meine soll in
ihrer komfortzone sich freiwillig zum
dank hab ich mich zählt und die un
hätten und es ist an ihre lebensrealität
als ich bei jedem zweiten us konzerns
mit irgendwie die einzige frau in der
schweiz hat bundesrätin simonetta
sommaruga im jahr 2018 eine weiche
frauenquote in börsennotierten
unternehmen durchgesetzt wird sie nicht
erreicht muss das unternehmen sich
erklären
aber warum nur eine weiche quote wenn
ich sehe wie ich kämpfen musste um diese
so genannte weiche quote durchzubringen
dass bei mal im nationalrat an 93 zu 94
stimmen bei 2 enthaltungen
also das war eigentlich dauernd auf
messers schneide dass diese vorlage
überhaupt durchkommt tier schon gerne
verbindlich oder ja klar dass ich mich
auch dann also auch in norwegen
orientiert und die hatten ja dann eine
sehr harte quote aber schauen sie in der
schweiz politik machen heißt auch immer
das machbare suchen und ich habe gerne
resultat
dafür erntete simonetta sommaruga nicht
nur lob sondern auch kritik
ohnehin wird über frauen in öffentlichen
funktionen anders berichtet als über
männer meint sie wir haben mittlerweile
kenne ich diese art der frauen zu
kritisieren in der ist sie eine mutig
dann macht sie weniger angst hat man ja
in deutschland auch immer wieder
versucht die bundeskanzlerin soll in ein
schema hinein zu pressen oder dann sind
die frauen aber man wird ja frauen zum
teil vor dass sie gut vorbereitet sind
oder dass sie kontrolliert sind dann
denke ich jeweils ja möchten sie eine
unkontrollierte bundesrätin möchten sie
eine unvorbereitete bundesrätin es
spannend eigentlich das zum teil
objektive oder qualitäten die an sich
positiv besetzt sind bei frauen dann
häufig negativ sind auch annegret kramp
karrenbauer wertvollen medienboard
scharf kritisiert
[Musik]
so aus der schweiz betrachtet fand ich
immer dass eigentlich die presse und die
medien sie sehr hart angefasst haben das
hat möglicherweise was mit dem thema
frau zu tun das hat aber glaube ich vor
allen dingen was damit zu tun dass ich
eben über diese monate auch als
potenzielle kanzlerkandidaten eben im
fokus stand und betrachtet worden bin
und die wird in der regel oder der wird
in der regel einer scharfen betrachtung
unterzogen
merken sie beruflich dass man sie anders
behandelt jetzt im negativen und
positiven sinn weil sie eine frau sind
ja ich kann mich gut erinnern als ich
das allererste mal für den bundestag
kandidiert habe da gab es eine
pressekonferenz der ist einigermaßen
aussichtsreich platziert und kandidaten
und ich weiß noch ich habe mich den
ganzen tag vorbereitet überlegt was kann
ich in den zwei drei minuten die ich
habe am politischen botschaften setzen
wie bringe ich mein programm rüber und
dann war am nächsten tag ein großer
artikel über diese pressekonferenz in
wird man sagen drei viertel des artikels
hat sich befasst mit der frage welche
frau hatte was an und das ist dass wir
einfach so typisch und das spielt nach
wie vor eine rolle und das ist glaube
ich auch einer der gründe gewesen
weshalb sich angela merkel mit ihrer
strengen kleiderordnung einfach dieser
thematik entzogen hat bewusst entzogen
hat
immer unterstützt wurde annegret kramp
karrenbauer von der frauen union der cdu
sie existiert seit über 70 jahren und
ist damit die älteste politische
frauenorganisation deutschlands von der
vorsitzenden annette widmann mauz möchte
ich wissen warum es solche frauen
bündnisse immer noch braucht und in die
fernseh frauen auf den weg zur macht
unterstützen können
es braucht diese bündnisse um frauen
nach vorn zu bringen um ihnen einfluss
gestaltungsmacht zu geben und vor allen
dingen ihre erfahrungen ihre sichtweisen
auch wirklich präsent zu machen und
deshalb braucht es solange wir keine
gleichberechtigte gesellschaft sind auch
weiterhin politische
frauenorganisationen und politische
lobby verbände von frau die hat die
frauen union dann speziell die
politische laufbahn von annegret kramp
karrenbauer beeinflusst
annegret kramp karrenbauer war über
viele jahrzehnte in der frauen union
aktiv sie ist es bis heute sie hat auch
dieses netzwerk nie verleugnet sondern
es sich darauf gestützt und die frauen
union ist sicherlich auch ein
wesentlicher faktor gewesen der sie zum
parteivorsitz gebracht hat ihr ist die
frauen union sind die anliegen von
frauen wichtig und sie pflegt diese
kameradschaft unter freundinnen in der
cdu auch sehr intensiv
ich habe ja auch nichts verraten heute
verstehe ich sie gerade eben im kabinett
hätten wir nehmen das was ich jetzt habt
ihr jetzt gegessen ob sie ihren gesagt
haben mit nehmen sie die interviews
machen aber ich habe letztlich aber ich
hab in bern stelle ich simonetta
sommaruga dieselbe frage uns eigentlich
auch zu den frauen bündnissen oder wie
wichtig ist dieser zusammenhalt diese
verbände von frauen oder frauen
organisationen
ja ich glaube frauen sind generell nicht
so gut organisiert wir haben die
frauenorganisationen aber für mich
persönlich war eigentlich immer wichtig
auch mit meiner täglichen arbeit also
jetzt in der politik einfach bündnisse
mit frauen zu schließen
ich habe die lohngleichheit erwähnt ich
habe dort wirklich mit frauen aus allen
parteien geschaltet wie machen wir das
ich habe die frauenquote ins parlament
gebracht ganz schwierig am anfang alle
waren skeptisch und dann einfach immer
wieder bündnisse suchen mit frauen nicht
nur den frauen themen sondern auch in
anderen themen finanzthemen
wirtschaftsthemen
da habe ich gute erfahrungen gemacht
weil auf die frauen konnte ich mich dann
wirklich meistens verlassen bis am
schluss und das stärkt uns natürlich und
wird das auch oft von vielen frauen
unterschätzt was das aus nach frauen
solidarität untereinander wird auch oft
irgendwie weggeredet schlecht geredet ja
ich habe eigentlich den eindruck die
macht der männer ist frauen zu spalten
das war wenn man sich geschichte in der
schweiz anschaut zum frauenstimmrecht
eigentlich dass der wichtigste hebel war
frauen immer wieder gegeneinander
auszuspielen
und das muss man als frau durchschauen
wenn wir frauen gleichberechtigt an der
macht teilhaben wollen dann müssen wir
uns gegenseitig unterstützen findet
simonetta sommaruga ganz bewusst pflegt
sie deshalb ihre beziehungen zu frauen
beruflich wie privat
sie stellt mich darum einer langjährigen
weggefährtin vor
andrea burgener würfe im beatrice von
wattenwyl haus treffe ich mich mit den
beiden
dieses steht im herzen der berner
altstadt
die schweizer regierung empfängt hier
staatsgäste und nutzt es für politische
gespräche
[Musik]
zumindest in den bildern die frauenquote
ist sehr schön säfte wächst hier drin
ist die frage ob wir gut abgebildet der
welches klar dass sich ein haus das sehr
stark von männern dominiert war und das
haus wird oder wurde lange sich frauen
von männern genutzt
aber jetzt sollten wir frauen in der
landesregierung dafür dass da auch
frauen hinkommen das ist auch schön dass
sie heute beide davon
andrea burgen der würfel ist ebenfalls
politikerin
im unterschied zu simonetta sommaruga
allerdings auf gemeinde ebene
[Musik]
sie sind beide in der
sozialdemokratischen partei und sie
kennen sich schon sehr sehr lange
wie hat diese freundschaft eigentlich
angefangen wie haben sie sich
kennengelernt weil in den 80er jahren
anfangen 8 milliarden tragen
etwa 2 23 jahre alt ich habe begonnen im
haus geschlagene frauen zu arbeiten nach
dienst und hat dann auch im verein als
im vorstand mitgearbeitet und da warst
du dabei
ich habe größten respekt gehabt vor dir
ich sage jetzt nicht angst aber du warst
so klar und so das müssen wir so regeln
und das muss so gemacht werden habe ich
schon beeindruckt ich bin von einer
kollegin von angefragt worden ob ich da
gerne im vorstand mitarbeiten würde und
ich kann mich gut erinnern dass ich als
nichtjurist in die verträge aufgesetzt
habe
und nein bei mir das dann wichtig war
dass diese frauen die für das frauenhaus
professionell arbeiten dass die auch die
richtigen arbeitsbedingungen haben und
in dem zusammenhang ich weiß noch genau
in welchem türer wir fassen
da haben wir hab ich dich auch
kennengelernt ich habe mich da als sehr
schüchtern war wirklich als sehr
schüchtern aber vielleicht war es ebenso
beeindruckt und näher
ich bin nach politisiert worden im
blauen haus ich habe wirklich gesehen
gewalt an frauen ist nicht nur einfach
pech gehabt und den falschen mann
gewählt sondern als gesellschaftliches
thema und ich habe mich dann ich habe
dann begonnen im rahmen dieses
frauenhaus der veranstaltungen zu machen
wo man darüber gesprochen hat und ich
habe plötzlich gemerkt ich habe eine
stimme wenn ich für sie einstehen kann
und dann kann ich hin stehen und dann
kann ich auch sprechen und dann bin ich
nicht mehr schüchtern als es das thema
hat mich begleitet und habe mich auch
vielleicht ein stück weit auch stark
gemacht
und mir eine eine rolle gegeben die ich
bis heute eigentlich auch sehr gerne
angst nicht mehr so schüchtern und ich
meine in erinnerung zu haben dass du
dazu mal schon sehr oft mit dem fahrrad
unterwegs warst ist das möglich da habe
ich das recht minuten reden
ich war sicher mit dem fahrrad unterwegs
habe ich würde sagen ich habe mit k4
gespielt als mit dem fahrrad
ich habe damals auf den hauskonzerten
gespielt dann organisiert worden war ab
und zu auch unterwegs ich habe herrn
eingraviert rio und ein klavierquartett
ich habe eigentlich immer gerne zusammen
gespielt mit anderen ja das finde ich
jetzt etwas vom schönsten mit gemeinsam
musik zu machen das hat mit politik
finde ich sehr viel zu tun da ist man ja
auch zusammen und wenn es gut läuft in
sternstunden der politik ist das häufig
auch ein kreatives zusammen etwas
entstehen lassen
simonetta sommaruga ist ausgebildete
pianistin und spielt auch heute noch oft
klavier manchmal zusammen mit kollegen
ihr zb mit gesundheitsminister albers
und manchmal allein sie brauche das
instrument um abstand von der politik zu
gewinnen
ich habe jeweils das gefühl so wendy
wenn die welt aus den fugen ist und die
ist ja immer wieder und im moment
vielleicht sogar besonders stark aus den
fugen
dann hat mich diese musik zurück mit
einer immer in ordnung und das ist für
mich ein ganz besonderer moment und die
musik das ist das was in meinem leben
wir wirklich als mein raum geblieben ist
in einem amt das er sehr stark nach
außen gerichtet ist und da hilft mir die
musik oder kind mit die musik dazu mich
wirklich eben auch wieder zu orientieren
nach innen dass es für frauen wie
simonetta sommaruga enorm wichtig ist
auch ein leben abseits der macht zu
führen leuchtet mir ein
martha schultz wiederum betonen dass
hier macht eigentlich gar nicht so
wichtig sei sie sind ja eine der
einflussreichsten unternehmen in
österreich was bedeutet an der macht
ihr einfluss ist bin eine gewählte
funktionären also man hat man sehr viel
vertrauen mitgegeben
bei frauen in der wirtschaft weil die
band gewählt dass ich wurde in allen
bereichen gewählt und das ich habe sehr
große auftrag eine sehr große
verantwortung und das wort macht ist ein
negativ belastet also ein gleichrichter
konnte das von thun und wird dass er das
wort macht tauschen mit
verantwortungsvoll führen
annegret kramp karrenbauer ist heute
nicht mehr ganz so mächtig wie schuler
heute gebe ich die verantwortung als
parteivorsitzende zurück vom cdu
parteivorsitz ist sie zurückgetreten und
damit auch von der kandidatur als
kanzlerin und auch ihre zeit als
verteidigungsministerin könnt ihr mit
den wahlen im herbst zu ende gehen
nehmen frauen vielleicht auch einfacher
abschied von macht wichtig ist dass man
neben dem abend das einem dann auf macht
verleiht oder ausland auf zeit sich
dessen immer bewusst ist es ist immer
nur auf zeit und dass man vor allen
dingen dann eben auch noch einsätze dann
ein anderes leben hat und den eigenen
wert nicht an dieses amt und an die
macht die damit verbunden ist hängt wenn
man diese innere unabhängigkeit hat dann
kann man auch von macht abschied nehmen
kennen sie das oder das kann ich
vielleicht fällt uns frauen der abschied
von der macht tatsächlich leichter als
den männern
erst müssen wir aber mal mächtig werden
und da scheint mir am wichtigsten dass
wir uns endlich gegenseitig unterstützen
der satz der mich jetzt am meisten
beschäftigt ist wirklich der die macht
der männer ist die spaltung der frauen
was denkst du warum ich hab da schon
eine hypothese könnte es vielleicht
daran liegen dass es halt für frauen
fast über jahrtausende eigentlich nichts
gebracht hat sich mit frauen zu
solidarisieren also es hat halt die
firma männer in machtpositionen um mit
frauen arbeiten hat sie nichts gebracht
man hat macht eigentlich umfeld sind wir
gehen mal mit gutem beispiel voran
[Musik]
warum wurden frauen seit jahrtausenden
daran gehindert macht zu erlangen
und was tun sie wenn sie selber macht
haben leben sie macht wenn das teilt
eure fragen und gedanken dazu mit uns
filmemacherinnen würde mich sehr freuen
ja hier in den kommentaren
[Musik]